20-17 is shaping up to be a great year  for ups for fans and now even more games  are on the way I'm Tony and this  GameSpot news update is bringing back  the classics if you're a jak and daxter  fan you'll be happy to know that the  series is making the jump to ps4 that  includes jak and daxter jak 2 jak 3 and  the spin-off jak X combat racing no  pricing a release date has been  announced but the games are headed to  the PSN store sometime in 2017 be sure  you're subscribed to GameSpot to be the  first to know when more games get  announced as per usual these ps2 on ps4  games will be upscaled to 1080p and will  include Trophy share play and Remote  Play support the PSN library already  contains classics like red dead revolver  and Psychonauts but if you want more  PlayStation goodness right now why not  check out our history up persona video  [Music]